hello everybody my name is Rihanna
Dillon and I am delighted to welcome you
to BAFTAs hair and makeup design session
so joining me we have Donald Carey and
Ivana congratulations on your
nominations things thank you before we
start just tell us a little bit about
your role what films you've worked on oh
god I always forget what I worked on
well I'm a makeup and hair designer I
work with Carrie quite a few times
mm-hmm and it's always a great fun we
worked together on cold mountain with
the hours together a few ones and to
forget and today for the darkest hour
mm-hmm
I'm a hairdresser and I vote obviously
with Havana and I've worked with Donald
twice and we did Blade Runner together a
most recent project together but like
speed dating isn't I know obviously
Blade Runner with Carrie we'd worked
together years earlier on I really loved
the Human Stain and Nicole Kidman and
Anthony Hopkins a long time ago I was
and I've been around for a few years a
stronger nocturnal animals last year
some fabulous films thank you and so
what I really love is like backstage all
you guys you all know each other and you
love each other and you're so passionate
about each other's work like it's just
really lovely to see ya and right first
of all let's have a look at Blade Runner
let's have a little clip and then you
can talk through your work
welcome back sir you want to join you
the new model server before shipment an
angel should never enter the kingdom of
heaven without a gift can you at least
pronounce a child is born
no model
let us see her then
[Music]
by hello hello a boy
you alone I have to come play with us
all then a selfie - boss okay
it's fine
wanna buy led cigarette
oh you don't even smile didn't you hear
your friends don't you know what I am
yeah
guy eating rice what's that it's a tree
I've never seen a tree before it's
pretty it's dead now
who takes a dead tree
you're not gonna kill me are you depends
what's your model number why don't you
go to my eye and find out
[Music]
you're electro girls
what a day
if you look lonely I can fix that
you look like good job
so talk me through the conversations
that you were having with the director
with the other heads of department to
create the design of these characters
don't go ahead it was very collaborative
but really I'd be lying to not say it
was a challenge because we had very
little time exactly in pretty much
everything so we all out of kit I mean
things with with Ryan we were you know
none of us are really fortunate to do a
film chronologically but this one really
was ass backwards absolutely as we had
to start from the you know the very
final scenes of the film establishing
Ryan and trying to imagine editorially
and and through the narrative what he
would look like and it was it always you
know it doesn't always look complicated
to people but we could do it understand
like that takes a second and you get
locked into something and you have one
opportunity and it's a one take and
you've established something and and
that's it but I think the pink joy was a
huge source of anxiety I think so yeah
because everyone's idea of pink you know
I finally I think when I left LA I went
into the beauty supplier and just
thought oh my god is it the you know we
were getting sketches from concept from
the director everyone's idea of pink if
you ask 10 people what is pink they will
tell you well this is pink this is 20
different shades between yeah and you
know I'm lucky enough to have worked
with Denis and Roger that I just would
go to Roger and say what the hell like
what is it we have no time it was
shooting two days later and I just we
were painting
swatches and he said bubblegum bubblegum
pink obviously and no but you know a
Cuban girl with us you know not an ivory
skin started pulling a little bit most
to it
then but that's how we got to it and
then trying to get the blood right so
that there was a reflection and this
blood looking a little bit pink it's
always a very Roger Deakins thing to
have a reflection and it worked really
well and fantastic made us look good and
the question is what kind of hair is
gonna go with the pink yeah you know was
it is it should it be on the lavender
side not to kink not to purple you know
instead of so we were testing basically
shock bought wigs because you know
that's the only availability we have
because we're up against it and that
scene was filmed in pre-production
basically remember we sort of like four
days into when Anna was there that was
our camera test yet was that camera test
basically it was that no that was their
camera we didn't have time to have
anything made it had to be I hit the
ground running basic you know and
luckily I had some great people working
with me little great with color and we
worked crazy color but we wanted didn't
want it to look like a short week
obviously and even though she's a
character that metamorphosis into many
different causes I still wanted to have
a strong look and I had this idea of
this sort of sphinx-like characters sort
of like almost like a sort of predator
sort of image and that's where we come
up with that hairdo in the color and
shape and that reveal of Jared Leto's
character presumably when it is a
character like that where they're in
darkness and you're sort of there's that
tension you're waiting for what he looks
like
is there a certain pressure on you guys
to make it look sloppy and for the
audience to kind of pull back I think I
had a heart attack I did because you
know what care is saying with the
testing period this is really typical
now in filmmaking where the pre shoots
and camera tests have really become I
think we all feel it where suddenly
let's shoot this because it's we're at
this location but we're still in our
pre-production stage of fittings and
hair and makeup and people you know will
decide and I was quite overwhelmed
because we were you know as he's
shooting with Ryan every
all day prepping the girls as they came
in all the actors who were coming in for
cameos we didn't know who was playing
Wallace it was quite not guarded secret
having to really two days before the
shoot arrived on the weekend we're
shooting on Monday you know so there was
a many different discussions of how we
should look we couldn't cut his hair
because he was working on another
production and so we had limitations of
what we could do you know is either
ponytails or down the lenses felt like
you know didn't the studio were
concerned and I have to say they're such
wonderful production company because
they looked at so many actors and it was
availability and that's kind of a newer
thing now in our industry where actors
are don't you find where actors are on
five other projects and they're trying
to squeeze something in but they can't
change the hair
they can't shave so I think my anxiety
became when Alcon and sony and denis
villeneuve said what are we gonna do
with him the contact lenses became a
thing and i just got on to stacy Sumner
provision care in LA where Jarrod was
but it wasn't so simple because he then
wanted them based on a character of a
man he knew just you know throw me a
little bit purple and we had just shot
15 hour days in hungry Los Angeles is
nine hours behind I'd get back to the
hotel at ten o'clock at night and then
start that and this would go on for a
while but we were very lucky and that
they hand-painted and we piggyback them
two sets of lenses there was one option
to do a bald cap and I would say we did
it we did a quick test in LA through a
shop that I like to work with and then
again in Hungary and I hope they
wouldn't go for it because it just
started to look caricature
and now that I look at it I'm so
relieved because Denis would never hire
me again if I didn't do it is it started
to look a little a combo sort of Austin
Powers meets a James Bond and it wasn't
the world with one and the brilliant
other people who do it but it would have
not been good for this and I'm yeah so
that's that was quite a source of
anxiety yeah and having the actors at
the last minute with hair wise that sort
of thing and Denis doesn't like wigs but
no the scripted anna changes into eleven
different causes so there's no other way
around
i'm weeks really yeah so she where i had
to go there basically and to sell it to
him in and he went along with it it was
great and and there cut the character
Mariette which you just saw with the
sort of dirty beige pink care so if I
wanted everything to look a little bit
lifeless and a little bit colorless
almost like she'd picked up the week out
of the bin somewhere and put it on her
head you know so rather than it being an
obvious sort of this is my look of the
time sort of things so and I sort of
went yeah as a research thing I went
back I mean obviously a little bit 70s
with a sort of like rock shake sort of a
little bit harder but also wanted for
our main characters take the the color
out of their hair almost make it look
like it's sort of dank and it's a dark
steamy dead world sort of with no sort
of sunshine things in their life so
getting rid of all our blondes that were
rocking up for scream death do you have
a preference between working with wigs
and real hair or do you think it's okay
I I love wings because you know what
you're gonna be getting every day but I
think it's a great challenge to work
with someone's hair I mean in this one
we worked basically most of the actors
had their own hair but in the situation
because of the humidity of the set and
the steam machines and everything else
was there it was
about structure of hair was about
keeping it close to the head and also
for the CGI sort of when and it goes
into different characters and things
like this to be able to morph them in I
couldn't have big hair small hair did
are paired down here sort of it so it
had to have a a sense of of closeness in
head shapes so we can morph them
backwards and forwards okay well
speaking of wigs let's have a look at
darkest hour and you can talk us through
the design of that carries of wig genius
right away
thank you
it's later morning follow me
[Music]
Lonnie thanks sir
[Music]
okay Sonia that's need-to-know and you
don't pay for the BMC you certainly
sleeping quarters when you miss the last
train
that's the map room no women allowed
what departments this indiscretion and
conversation or any other form within or
without these rooms regarding what
happens here is a statutory offence
punishable about two two years
imprisonment with hard labor clear
crystal good
that's the War Cabinet Room you never I
don't mean to be rough on you that
them's the rules this is the typist
school ladies here's you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
do you have something it's like the
complete opposite of Blade Runner
because you have something very specific
that you have to emulate you have to be
historically accurate so what kind of
challenges does that throw up or is it
actually better to be able to work from
something well finding a love listening
to Carrie and we work together a couple
of times on different projects and what
struck me with what you said about
blender on is very similar to the
process that you go through on a period
movie like darkest hour because they're
very character-driven so an ordinary so
modern-day rom-com might not have the
same involved process that Blade Runner
had and the darkest hour has so they're
two very different films but the process
I think is very similar and when you
work with very visual directors which we
both have they have a very clear idea or
not a clear idea what they want and what
they don't want and you have to provide
that so with the darkest hour the
challenge was that we were dealing with
stuff with the material which is very
well known to people historical material
that a lot of people know a lot about
and that's always scary because I always
think you know people will actually
remember the people in question the
newspapers were full of in archives and
you know people remember that time still
and also we do remember those a lot of
people that we actually depict in this
film so you have to kind of honor that
so you have the great sense of
responsibility to do it properly so that
was a bit of a challenge and this one
apart from that Joe Wright is incredibly
I mean every time I work with him I get
nominated so well because he's so visual
and he always has a great idea this
was difficult because of the you know
literally we had to go through a list of
characters and go into people remember
what actually look like and here we go
of course it was like really so that's
the kind of thing that you have to or
the general Ironside I was like no one
knows no they do it was a very important
figure everyone knows what so you have
to kind of do historical justice to some
characters and then of course what's
great about what we do is you provide
information that the script doesn't so
when characters appear on the screen
directly quite often wants to you the
viewer to know what's going on in that
person's life absolutely so we have this
great responsibility to make people look
ill or worried or scared or all those
different things or fabulous yeah so
that's become so that's where the
process is very similar in research and
application but yes of course this is
you know of course as well it's nineteen
forties just the turn of you know thirty
late thirties and forties and of course
that wasn't very glamorous time in in
history so that's also quite important
to make sure that people don't look too
shiny and to knew when to brilliant
because it was a very difficult time is
there a moment where you know you're
doing the makeup and their hair for an
actor and you can see them sort of them
disappearing and their character
emerging is that must be quite a special
yeah and I think that's that's the best
thing about what we do because it
literally a lot of the actors that we
work with need their transformation to
be able to play the character and they
can't do it without and that's why
carrying works with lots of wigs because
you need to change if you've done change
person's hair and the eyebrows you don't
change the character so it's kind of in
a way that's start there and then you
see them emerge and then they can
actually play different characters very
easily and also the actors like to take
it all off at the end of the day you
know become themselves home which is
also great to see ya to shed that kind
of an action I like to know it's on a
block somewhere but we have it today
let's talk a little bit more generally
do you have a piece of kit that you just
could not do without I know you must
have loads but if there like one well I
do I was very I've been very fortunate
to work with amazing people but I
started with Nami Dawn and Jenny circle
who are both BAFTA nominated in Oscar
winners and and I learned from basically
when there was not much makeup he didn't
you know he wasn't very scientific at
the time it was very quite primitive and
I learnt Jennie shirker would always say
if you you can do the entire movie out
of a Crowl and grease paint palette and
I still think today you can I think
that's the only kit you need it's it's a
very primitive color combination kit but
you can still to this day it could even
color hair with that you can do anything
with it and I think still to this day
with all the science that's probably
what we need the most and I think we
have some images actually as Bladerunner
so we could get those up and then we
could maybe you could just talk a little
bit about okay so look here we have I
mean it looks sort of fairly basic but
these were just these were kind of
really quick remember carry these were
sort of pretest would get all the BG and
we had a few minutes to sort of play
just so I could get Denis to sort of
sign off on intensities of them and that
way on the day is he's a very keen eye I
would say more so Roger on the
background and which I think are
relaying for system so the trash Mesa
really all are groups of background
visually would make a statement and I we
just get them in for a day and this
would be the original reference right
obviously and then elements
I think thereafter we just grabbed a
Taser and the contacts and the contacts
which you know were were a fear for me
because you know actors always say oh
it's fine it's really comfortable fit in
Los Angeles by Whitney and dr. Sumner
and the day of they heard and you know
that's but we had a phenomenal lens Tech
in Hungary I have to say was the best
I've ever worked with in my life yes and
she could really diffuse yeah because
that was tricky right let's turn it over
to the audience and any of you guys have
any questions for our panel yes there's
a microphone just coming to you another
question for Ivana you said that there
are a lot of characters where you had to
be very aware of for how people perceive
them because everyone remembers what
they look like
were there any what was there sort of a
level of which you stopped doing that so
were there any sort of mid-level
generals or whatever who you didn't do
that with because you stopped doing that
basically well that's a really brilliant
question because there is lots of
different reasons and factors why you
would consider that and one of them is a
budget of every film and the other one
is the time factor and then simply the
practicality of letting the actors be
able to do their job properly so we are
literally at one point I said to Joe
right a director and the producers like
what point what cast number do we stop
insisting that we try and make the the
characters look like the real people and
we decided that it's not necessarily
kind of it doesn't go from 1 to 15
it was literally we chose the characters
and the actors to help the actors do
their job properly so there were certain
characters that we paid great attention
to that they're not in the film very
much but it was really important to get
them
- look period and to look like the
person so that will help them to become
that character better so it was a right
it was a mixture of you know certain
characters are really it only for a day
or two and we spend a lot of time on but
yes I mean mainly I would you know I did
my research through all the you know
archival footage and stuff and literally
some of the character some of the some
of the some of the politicians I really
never heard of but they were in the
cabinet and you think well actually we
should pay attention to those but it was
really to help the actors perform thank
you and we have time for one more quick
question and yet this gentleman just
here on the third row general question
how do you maintain a work-life balance
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
that never happens
no it's I'm really it's a great question
and I don't know the answer other than
for people starting out if I could do it
all over again and I've done it for 32
years 33 which means I started when I
was five I would honestly say because
life changes and things happen and I
love the work I think we all do anybody
here loves the work and the artistry and
but you know it there's a big sacrifice
which I certainly wasn't aware of and
they don't teach you that when you're
coming up I wish they'd learned a little
bit more balance of looking after one's
health and eating properly and it's very
difficult and it's not an excuse because
people will say well that's just lame
but no matter where you go to work in
the world I mean to work 16 you know my
last mom still on the phone we're doing
80 hours a week it is a bit once you get
to a certain
you think this is who's doing that do
you know and actually a friend who's a
resident at cedars-sinai who said to me
you guys do residents hours except you
do it for 40 years they do it until they
qualify you can only do it when if you
love it that's exactly yeah otherwise
you won't be able to sustain all that
but also now with the with amazing
opportunities in television things have
got worse because now you get these
incredible projects with great directors
who pull you into things which are 7
months long and you're doing suddenly
find yourself doing working with five
directors who shoot on the same project
at the same time and you're doing 10
hours of television which of amazing
content and you have to invent how to do
it you have to actually not just be a
makeup and hair designer you have to you
have to in help the producers how to
organize a department which never used
to happen we used to be told when to
turn up and what we do now we have to
tell them yeah because we become experts
in what we do which is a great fun but
after seven months it's something to go
that's no work to add to what Ivana
saying that I think it's now time for
the very senior people in the industry
or people who are maybe it's the tail
end of a career to really educate and
start getting makeup makeup and hair
designers we have to take this back we
have to become very responsible as
associations as guilds academies to
start in the makeup industry as hair has
changed that what we're expected to do
you know as Ivana said where we used to
you know turn up you know but now I mean
I started on films that were zero budget
films in Canada for the National Film
Board of Canada for it was me plus one
you know and now we're on films where I
have 30 and hungry 30 additionals
who manages that I mean we need to start
working broader scale like other
departments and I do think politically
it's the makeup and hair have got to
step up now
so we can stay working and do our craft
and stay healthy yeah I think that's a
great piece of advice to end on thank
you so much
[Applause]
you